anthony fauci 81 años trabajar hasta
diciembre como asesor del presidente yo
bailén para enfrentar el kobe y como
director de el instituto nacional de
alergias y enfermedades infecciosas
en un comunicado falso que ya lleva 50
años trabajando para el gobierno y que
empezó en el gobierno del ex presidente
bueno brigham dijo que estaba listo ya
para dar el próximo paso profesional su
renuncia no llega del todo por sorpresa
en una entrevista este fin de semana
digo que estaba todavía con ánimo con
energía con pasión para inspirar nuevas
generaciones desde afuera del gobierno
al respecto al presidente joe biden
agradeció las contribuciones del doctor
fauci a la salud pública agregando que
con su trabajo había salvado vidas no
sólo en eeuu sino también en el mundo su
renuncia se da después recordemos de
quiero ser walannsky directora del
centro de control y prevención de
enfermedades aceptar a que quedaron
cortos en muchos aspectos en la
respuesta frente al cob y tuvieron
algunos errores bastante públicos hay
que mencionar que falsee recibió también
varias amenazas
su vida como asesora de donald trump y
de joe biden tras enfrentarse a varios
senadores republicanos que cuestionaban
sus recomendaciones y medidas de
prevención contra el cob y de en eeuu